déjà qu est-ce que c'est la définition
du racisme moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
prenne soin de l'état premier le mauvais
c'est la vôtre a en gros le racisme
c'est considérer qu'il existe des
différences entre les races et par
rapport à ça faire une échelle de 2d
degré de perfection entre chacune
nous on est humaniste moi je vois pas de
rail magnétique eut lierse herbages voie
d'être humains en face de moi moi je
peux avoir quelqu'un originaire
d'afrique du nord gr d'asie originaire
de n'importe quel pays je vois un être
humain je vais pas regarder quand on dit
le programme du rassemblement national
ya quand même des discriminations alors
vous allez me dire ou parce que dans
notre programme je suis désolé on n'est
jamais tombé dans le piège du racialisme
que veulent nous tendre à chaque fois
nos adversaires jamais une seule fois on
a toujours défendu qu'un être humain
était un être humain
on n'a jamais laissé entendre qu'ils
pourraient faire des différences entre
les uns et les autres et on a toujours
prôné le respect de la laïcité
donc je veux dire on est vraiment
exemplaire là dessus c'est pour ça que
je suis étonné de voir toutes ces
diffamations qui sont faites à
l'encontre de notre parti qui est un
parti tout ce qui est plus républicaine
aujourd'hui ce parti il monte tout
simplement il fait peur parce qu'il dit
des vérités et parce qu'on dérange si on
essaye de ressortir à chaque fois ce
spectre du nazisme mais je crois que
tous ces gens là ne savent plus ce que
c'était le nazisme
aurélien fâché mais tout simplement
enfin vous êtes en train de dire ok pour
vous les français sont les mêmes d'où
qu'ils viennent et c'est jeudi les êtres
humains non mais la france s'inquiète de
savoir si elle va avoir assez de jeunes
ou non pour cotiser pour sa retraite
pour quoi vous voulez absolument donner
de l'argent aux gens pour qu'ils fassent
des enfants ça vous fait tellement peur
qu'ils aient des gens qui viennent de
l'étranger
ouais c'est vraiment vous fait pas de
différence mérité l'argent mais moi je
sais toi tu veux pas qu'elle gens qui
viennent de l'étranger n'ont jamais mais
si mais si on fait pas je m'étais
d'avancé contre les français en fonction
de là où ils viennent fois où les
subventionner comme ça absolument des
femmes reste à la maison pour qu'elle
fasse des enfants en fait vous savez que
ce pays ce pays je peux pas vous laisser
ce pays il va avoir besoin de la
jeunesse va avoir besoin parce qu on en
a on a plus assez de jeunes pour
financer les retraites et autres et vous
vous acharnez c'est marqué dans votre
programme
on est prêt à tout faire pour les femmes
restent à la maison et pas des enfants
les femmes blanches française vous avez
pas dit on
st-juste marine le pen arrive il ya peu
de temps à l'afp l'un d'eux télé pour
dire effectivement moi je donne à ce
qu'ils restent chez eux aux fesses
blanches aux mamans non non vous ne
voulez vous ne mettez pas tous les
français sur la même échelle